en este vídeo voy a multiplicar 87 por
63 y no lo voy a hacer mediante un
proceso que sigue algunos pasos sino que
voy a usar la propiedad distributiva
para tratar de calcular esto que tenemos
aquí entonces voy a reescribir este 87 y
en lugar de escribir 63 como aquí voy a
escribir 60 más 3 el 63 lo voy a
escribir como 60 más 3 y cuál va a ser
el resultado de esto 87 por 63 a que va
a ser igual voy a copiar este 87 y lo
voy a poner aquí abajo
y tenemos 87 por 60 más 87 por 3
lo que estoy haciendo es distribuir el
87 87 por 60 87 por 3 y aquí vamos a
poner paréntesis para tener esto un poco
más claro y como calculamos este 87 por
60 bueno ahora puede escribir este 87
como 80 más 7 déjenme escribirlo así voy
a cambiar y voy a poner primero el 60
60 por 80 787
+ 3 por 87 y voy a copiar esto de aquí
para no tener que cambiar colores lo
copio y lo pego
y aquí tengo 3 por 87
y ya lo puse todo aquí para tenerlo más
claro este 87 por 60 es lo mismo que 60
por 87 y lo que vemos aquí 87 por 3 es
lo mismo que 3 por 80 más 7 y podemos
distribuir todavía más podemos escribir
aquí 60 por 80 más 60 por 7
+ 3 por 80 3 por 80 3 por 7 3 por 7
fíjense bien este 8 que tenemos aquí
representa 80 este 7 representa 7 este 6
representa 60 porque está en la posición
de las decenas igual que este 8 este 3
está en la posición de las unidades así
que representa sólo 3 y los estamos
multiplicando todos estamos
multiplicando 80 por 60 luego 80 por 3
también estamos multiplicando 7 por 67
por 3 y al final sumamos todo y cuando
sumamos todo tendremos el resultado de
la multiplicación así que lo que tenemos
aquí es 6 por 8 es igual a 48 pero
tenemos 60 por 80 así que es 4 mil 848 y
dos ceros
acá tenemos 60 por 7 es igual a 420 6
por 7 42 pero debemos multiplicar por 10
porque este es 60 y luego 3 por 80
seguimos la misma lógica 3 por 8 es 24
pero esto va a ser igual a 240 y al
final 3 por 7 es igual a 21 y para
obtener el resultado final vamos a sumar
todos estos números y probablemente
digan oye pero yo sé una manera más
rápida para resolver esto y lo que
quiero que vean es que por muy rápido
que lo puedan resolver no son procesos
mágicos o fórmulas especiales las que
nos dan el resultado aquí estamos
distribuyendo muy bien estos números
usando el sentido común y voy a sumar
todos estos números de este lado 4800
más 420 más 240 más 21 y aquí nos queda
120 más 40 más 20 es 80 800 más 400
igual a 1200 más 200 es igual a 1400 y
4000 más mil 5000 así que el resultado
final es 5 mil 481 esto es igual a 5 mil
481 y ustedes se pueden dar cuenta o
podrían pensar que es molesto estar
escribiendo toda esta distribución una y
otra vez pero es simplemente una manera
para que puedan visualizar todo esto y
ahora lo podemos escribir en una
cuadrícula para multiplicar 87 por 63
podríamos escribirlo de la siguiente
manera 87
87 por 60
+ 3 y podemos dibujar aquí una
cuadrícula cuando estamos multiplicando
dos dígitos por dos dígitos una
cuadrícula de dos por dos dos renglones
por dos columnas y lo que nos queda es
calcular el resultado 80 por 60 es igual
a 4800
60 por 7 es igual a 420 420 3 por 80 es
igual a 240 y aquí ponemos 240 y
finalmente 3 por 7 es igual a 21
21 y si los sumamos todos nos da como
resultado 5 mil 481 y ahora quiero
animarlos para que hagan esta misma
multiplicación 87 por 63 de la manera
tradicional que han aprendido y revisen
cada paso para que vean que todo esto
tiene sentido y que se den cuenta de que
lo que hacen es básicamente lo que
hicimos en este vídeo es lo que se hace
en las diferentes maneras para resolver
esta multiplicación y con este ejercicio
y con todo este vídeo lo que quiero es
que se den cuenta cómo se relacionan los
números cuando hacemos una
multiplicación y no solamente que
apliquen un método que sigan unos pasos
para obtener un resultado sin entender
que es lo que realmente está pasando